Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, wo gehst du eigentlich hin, um deine Privatsphäre ausleben zu können?
Also so richtig sicher, ne? Und so richtig privat fühle ich mich eigentlich nur im Sammeln.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 469 vom 14. September 2023.
Direkt aus dem Spielplatz der Möglichkeiten.
Hier leben wir unsere Freiheit aus und da können wir machen,
was wir wollen. Der Podcast ist sozusagen unsere Kapsel.
Spielplatz der Möglichkeiten.
Vollständig unbeobachtet auch.
Aber da ist auf jeden Fall der Sandkasten der sicherste Ort, oder?
Du meinst generell oder innerhalb des Podcasts?
Auf dem Spielplatz der Möglichkeiten.
Ja, das auf jeden Fall.
Also Finger weg vom Klettergerüst.
Da passieren richtig schlimme Sachen.
Oder wenn man auf der Wippe balanciert und abrutscht und so,
das sind alles ganz gefährliche Möglichkeiten.
Es sei denn, man hat einen Sandkasten da drunter, dann ist es nicht so schlimm.
Kommt drauf an wie weit da drunter der ist.
Stimmt schon. Oder wie stark wieder gewippt wurde.
Ist halt besser wenn der relativ, wenn der kommt, sag ich mal bevor deine Beine zu Ende sind.
Jaja, über Sandkasten werden wir heute noch reden, aber wir wollen in unserer
super kompakten Sendung heute anfangen mit, Feedback! Ja.
Machst du den Ersten?
Ja, mach ich.
Jörn schreibt uns zum Thema Digital Services Act und Störerhaftung,
auf die wir eingegangen sind in der letzten Sendung, zum DSA und der vermeintlichen
Regelungslücke der Störerhaftung für WLAN.
Das ist in der Verordnung ziemlich eindeutig geregelt. Artikel 4 DSA reine Durchleitung.
Bei der Durchführung eines Dienstes der Informationsgesellschaft, der darin besteht,
von einem Nutzer bereitgestellte Informationen in einem Kommunikationsnetz zu
übermitteln oder Zugang zu einem Kommunikationsnetz zu vermitteln,
haftet der Diensteanbieter nicht für die übermittelten oder abgerufenen Informationen, sofern er a.
Die Übermittlung nicht veranlasst, b. den Adressaten der übermittelnden Informationen
nicht auswählt und c, die übermittelten Informationen nicht auswählt oder verändert.
Damit existiert ein grundsätzlicher Haftungsausschluss für Dienste,
die nur Daten durchleiten und hierzu wird in der Wägungsgrund 28 explizit aufgeführt,
zu solchen Diensten gehören unter anderem lokale Funknetze, in Klammern WLAN,
DNS-Dienste, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt.
Wie Tim sagt, gilt die Verordnung unmittelbar. Die Verwirrung dürfte da eher
dadurch kommen, dass man in Deutschland dann immer wieder Ergänzungsgesetze
schreiben will für Dinge, die man teilweise gar nicht mehr regeln kann.
Okay, ja, interessanter Hinweis. Also der Kommentar bezieht sich ja darauf,
dass wir in der letzten Sendung der Nachricht geglaubt haben,
dass die Störerhaftung nicht mehr drin steht in der Gesetzesnovelle,
die durch den DSA veranlasst wird.
Und hier das findet jetzt im Prinzip, sagt Jörn, das ist richtig so,
weil man den Satz nicht mehr braucht. Das ist ja das Argument, was...
Ja, okay. Also die einzige Frage, die mir jetzt in dem Moment kommt,
ist, hier ist von der Durchführung eines Dienstes der Informationsgesellschaft
die Rede. So hat er es zumindest hier geschrieben. Finde den Begriff jetzt an
der Stelle ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Wenn ich jetzt ein Restaurant habe, bin ich dann eine Informationsgesellschaft?
Wo hast du denn Dienst der Informationsgesellschaft gelesen?
Ja ganz am Anfang, bei der Durchführung eines Dienstes der Informationsgesellschaft,
der darin beschäftigt wird.
Er hat es ja spezifisch gesagt, Ermittlungen nicht veranlasst,
Adressaten nicht auswählt und Informationen nicht auswählt und verändert,
damit existiert und dann sagen sie...
Achso, das bezieht sich auf den Diensteanbieter.
Lokale Funknetze, WLAN, DNS-Dienste und so weiter.
Ja genau, weil wenn ich jetzt ein Restaurant bin und ich biete halt ein WLAN
an, das ist ja so der Klassiker. Bin ich dann der Diensteanbieter?
Diensteanbieter ist die Formulierung.
Ja, du bietest ja einen Dienst an.
Ja gut, das weiß ich ja nicht, das ist ja juristisch deutsch, deutsch-juristisch.
Du würdest ja eigentlich sagen, das ist eine basale Infrastruktur,
die steht mir einfach zu, dass ich Internet in diesem Restaurant habe,
genauso wie ich auf die Toilette gehen kann und sich die Leute in der Küche
die Hände waschen müssen.
Du meinst, wenn ich den Leuten Suppe verkaufe, bin ich auch ein Diensteanbieter?
Suppe as a service.
Okay gut, naja ich bewerte das mal nicht, das war der Kommentar von Jörn,
wahrscheinlich kriegen wir noch andere Kommentare dazu.
Also mich hat der jetzt erstmal überzeugt.
Okay, dann ist ja eigentlich alles gesagt.
Na er sagt ja spezifisch, dass WLAN und DNS dazugehört, in Erwägungsgrund 28
wird es explizit benannt.
Ja WLAN ist benannt, die Frage ist für wen gilt das?
Also, könnte natürlich sein, dass das aus dem... Aber guck mal, also, noch mal.
Reine Durchleitung. Bei der Durchführung eines Dienstes der Informationsgesellschaft,
jetzt fragst du, was ist das?
Der Satz geht aber noch weiter. Der darin besteht, von einem Nutzer bereitgestellte
Information in einem Kommunikationsnetz zu übermitteln oder Zugang zu einem
Kommunikationsnetz zu vermitteln, haftet der Dienstanbieter nicht
für die übermittelten oder abgerufenen Informationen, Aber die Frage ist,
wie ist Diensteanbieter definiert in diesem Zusammenhang?
Gilt das auch für ein Restaurant? Das ist ja sozusagen die Frage.
Also als allererstes wird doch erstmal der Dienst beschrieben.
Ja und der Diensteanbieter ist derjenige, der haftet oder nicht haftet.
Und das ist ja die große Frage.
Bin ich jetzt sozusagen von der Haftung frei? Das bin ich nach diesem Text ja
nur, wenn ich als Diensteanbieter gelte.
Und die Frage ist, wenn ich ein Restaurant bin, bin ich das dann auch?
Also deine Frage ist jetzt, gilt das, wenn ich ein Restaurant habe und ich habe
Internet von Deutsche Telekom, ist dann die Deutsche Telekom der Diensteanbieter
oder ich als Restaurant, weil ich das WLAN Passwort rausgemacht habe? Ja.
Lass mir das offen bis zum nächsten Kommentar.
Kleinere Korrektur aber relevante Korrektur von André, wir haben uns bei der
Diskussion von Apple Scanning Plänen im Jahr vertan,
wir haben gesagt das hätten die vor einem Jahr angekündigt, das stimmt aber
nicht, das haben sie vor zwei Jahren angekündigt, dann gab es Gegenstimmen,
Tim und ich haben das ja auch diskutiert, es wird euch nicht überraschen,
Tim fand es super, was er für sich da ausgedacht hat.
Das habe ich nicht gesagt. Wieso drehst du mir die ganze Zeit meine Worte im
Mund herum, es ist nichts, es ist richtig.
Okay, was denn?
Ich habe lediglich versucht zu beschreiben, was meiner Meinung nach ihre Motivation
ist und warum sie das vorgeschlagen haben, das war alles, was ich getan habe.
Okay, dann war es angekündigt für iOS 15 und vor einem Jahr,
als dann iOS 15 kam, war es da nicht drin.
Also sie hatten gesagt, ja, okay, wir überlegen nochmal und dann kam iOS 15, war es nicht drin.
Und damit ist jetzt seit einem Jahr klar, dass sie es nicht machen und das Neue
ist jetzt nur, dass sie es auch noch mal beschrieben haben, ja,
und dass da auch nicht mehr mehr kommen wird.
Genau, dass sie die Pläne nicht verfolgen, weil es ist ja erstmal,
erstmal war es nur Postpon. Sie haben halt gesagt, okay, wir gehen dann nochmal
in die Diskussion. Das haben sie ja auch gemacht.
Und am Ende dieser Diskussion stand jetzt eben der in der letzten Sendung veröffentlichte
Text, dass sie halt sagen, machen wir jetzt auch nicht.
Wir machen nach wie vor diese Klein-Site-Scanning-Geschichten als Warnung,
wenn man selber was postet und so weiter oder auch empfängt,
dann greifen diese Mechanismen.
Ist man aber eben nicht mehr diese Automatik, die in der Diskussion war,
dass halt diese ganzen CSAM-Dateien über diesen speziellen Hashing-Algorithmus
erkannt und gemeldet werden.
So, das ist nicht drin, kommt auch nicht und Sie sind jetzt eigentlich voll
in diesem Modus mit, lasst euch was besseres einfallen.
Hier, Client-Side-Scanning geht nicht.
Beziehungsweise nicht in dem Ausmaß, wie sie es ursprünglich geplant haben.
So dann, zum Selbstbestimmungsgesetz möchtest du noch einen Kommentar vorlesen.
Genau, Alex schreibt, hallo, ich möchte mal meine persönliche Situation zum
Selbstbestimmungsgesetz schildern.
Ja, ich weiß, dass ich eine Folge zu spät bin.
Ich stehe momentan vor der Wahl, entweder ich lasse meinen Namen über das TSG
ändern, was heißt nochmal TSG?
Sexuellen gesetzt das alte Gesetz für Selbstbestimmung
das jetzt auch übrigens seinen Namen verlieren soll
ich glaube das Sicherlich auch eine der Gründe warum
sie abgekürzt wird Also entweder ich lasse meinen Namen über das TSG ändern
und bezahle ein paar tausend Euro für Gutachten und Gerichtsverfahren Und glaube
ich habe keinen Anspruch auf Prozesskostenhilfe oder ich warte und lasse meinen Namen über das SBG,
also Selbstbestimmungsgesetz ändern.
Beim SBG werde ich bei allen deutschen Sicherheitsbehörden als transzwangs geoutet,
muss dafür aber nicht bezahlen und nicht vor Gericht ziehen.
Um ehrlich zu sein, weiß ich wirklich nicht, was mir lieber ist.
Wie würdet ihr entscheiden?
Ja, das also, gut, wir hatten, also ich hatte ja in der Sendung,
als wir das besprochen haben, auch gesagt, da müssen wir mal einfach auf die
Perspektive der Leute warten, die dieses Gesetz betrifft und da haben wir jetzt
eine schöne Antwort und ich wüsste es jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch nicht so ganz.
Also ich kann, ich kann da überhaupt nichts zu sagen, weil ich einfach mich
nicht in diese Situation versetzen kann.
Ich glaube, wir wären auch die Falschen, da jetzt Rat zu geben.
Absolut.
Aber das werde ich mal mit ein paar Freundinnen und Freunden mal ansprechen, wie die das sehen.
Also sicherlich ist es auf jeden Fall auf der positiven Seite zu vermerken,
dass man nicht mehr Gutachten für teuer Geld erstellen muss.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine absolute,
also das weiß ich, dass das eine Demütigung und totaler Mist ist.
Ich habe nur tatsächlich nicht mehr mit Menschen jetzt spezifisch über diesen
einen Aspekt mit dieser Meldung an die Sicherheitsbehörden gesprochen seitdem,
weil eigentlich haben ja alle immer dem SBG entgegen gefiebert.
Ja, aber also ja, Alex, ich werde dir die Antwort jetzt nicht geben.
Und ich glaube, du hast vor allem das Dilemma auch ganz gut aufgezeigt.
Dann haben wir natürlich, wie sollte es auch anders sein, diverse Kommentare
zu unserem Exkurs über Google, die wir jetzt nicht alle vorlesen wollen.
Da gab es sozusagen immer wieder den Hinweis, welche Innovationen es ja noch gegeben habe.
AlphaFold wurde dort noch mal erwähnt. Ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher,
ob wir das erwähnt haben. Ich glaube, das haben wir nicht erwähnt,
aber das war ja in der Tat auch ein signifikanter Durchbruch im biochemischen Bereich.
Also AlphaFold ist ja dieses System, was quasi per AI-Modellen das Folding von
Proteinen vorhersagen kann und damit so ein paar seit Jahren ausstehende große
Probleme des Wissenschaftsbereichs gelöst hat.
Und natürlich auch generell die ganzen Transformer-Modelle, die Basis von Large Language Models etc.
Die ganze Debatte, ich will die jetzt nicht wieder komplett aufmachen,
aber ich glaube wir beide haben auch unterschiedliche Perspektiven gehabt.
Ja die übrigens auch sich nicht widersprechen.
Das ist das was mich auch so genervt hat. Die sich auch nicht widersprechen,
nur es ist halt die Frage was bewertet man.
Also wenn man jetzt sagt okay ich hab jetzt 25 Jahre Google und meine Perspektive
war okay so what has Google ever done for us so, also ist da irgendwas gutes bei rausgekommen?
Und aus meiner Perspektive haben sich natürlich viele Dinge angestoßen.
Es war immer so ein Nerdmagnet und ist es teilweise auch immer noch.
Also wir haben wirklich viele der besten Leute bei sich im Unternehmen andocken lassen.
Und in dem Zuge diverse wissenschaftlich technische Innovationen hervorgebracht.
Deine Perspektive war ja unter anderem auch davon geprägt, was da letzten Endes
bei rausgekommen ist. Vielleicht habe ich sie selber vertreten.
Niemand stellt ja in Abrede, dass ein Unternehmen, was für ein Vierteljahrhundert
existiert und in vielen dieser Jahre Milliarden Umsätze im zweistelligen Bereich macht,
dass die zwischendurch auch mal irgendwas Brauchbares erfinden müssen,
um weiter zu existieren. Das muss auch z.B.
Mercedes-Benz, die in einem 4. Jahrhundert eine ganze Menge großartige Dinge
erfunden haben, bin ich mir sicher, die das Autofahren besser gemacht haben
für Leute, aber halt nicht Elektroautos gebaut haben.
Und das wäre, das ist das, was ich eben bei Google denke, sie erfinden vielleicht
mal ab und zu was Brauchbares, aber sich selber nicht neu.
Aber du weißt, dass der Daimler den Hubmotor erfunden hat, den Elektromotor im Rad.
Gut, dann hat er umso besser.
Hat er gemacht.
Ja, ist ja richtig geil. Guck mal, hat er nichts draus gemacht,
haben die 100 Jahre nichts draus gemacht. Das ist doch genau mein Argument.
Aber okay, lass uns das jetzt nicht wieder anfangen.
Und Alpha Fold ist von Deep Mind, was sie dazu gekauft haben.
Jetzt kommt der Punkt. Und jetzt bitte ganz kurz zuhören, bevor jetzt die nächsten
Leute wieder von Transformer-Modellen anfangen.
Google, was hatten wir gesagt, 60 Milliarden Gewinn oder sowas.
Die Stanford-Universität arbeitet mit einem jährlichen Budget von 8 Milliarden.
Jetzt Vorsicht, diese ganzen Buden wie DeepMind und so,
die von Google ja dann gekauft wurden, Die sind an den Punkt dieser Innovationskraft
gekommen, mit einem sehr viel günstigeren Quotienten aus Geld,
was ihnen zur Verfügung steht und Innovationskraft.
Ja, also es scheint so zu sein, dass kleine Unternehmen mit sehr viel weniger
Kapital sehr viel erfolgreicher darin sind,
relevante Innovationen hervorzubringen, als Google, wenn man auf den Quotient
aus Innovation und zur Verfügung stehendem Kapital schaut.
Also wäre Google kleiner, wären sie innovativer oder vielleicht auch nicht.
Aber auf jeden Fall scheint, hat ihre Innovationskraft nicht mit der Größe und dem Umsatz skaliert.
Und jetzt weiß ich nicht genau, was jetzt irgendwie,
was wären das, 7, 7,5 Stanford-Universitäten ist dann Google vom Annual Budget.
Das ist bei denen allerdings nur der Gewinn.
Kann man wahrscheinlich nicht so gut vergleichen, wo jetzt pro Jahr aus einem
Dollar mehr Innovation rauskommt.
Aber eigentlich wollte ich mit diesem ganzen Thema nämlich zu der marktbeherrschenden
Stellung, weil ja ein Kartellverfahren gegen Google eröffnet wurde.
Vorher will ich dir aber noch die Gelegenheit geben, auch noch mal was zu sagen.
Tim.
Mia.
Willst du noch was sagen? Dazu. Zur Innovationskraft von Google?
Naja, also Innovationskraft hin und her, also das mit dem Don't be evil,
das hat halt nicht gut funktioniert.
Da hätte man nochmal dran arbeiten können. Mia ist halt, der Laden einfach super
suspekt, seitdem halt wirklich auch alles unter diesem Werbeverdienst Diktat steht.
Genau, und da kommen wir nämlich jetzt auch genau zu dem Kartellthema.
Also es gibt jetzt in den USA ein großes Kartellverfahren gegen Google,
das im Prinzip aus zwei weiteren, aus zwei vorangegangenen zusammengeführt wurde.
Und jetzt muss man sich überlegen, warum haben wir Kartellverfahren?
Die Idee ist, dass man davon ausgeht, dass marktbeherrschende Stellungen ausgenutzt
werden können. Es ist also noch nicht falsch, eine marktbeherrschende Stellung zu haben.
Und es ist eigentlich auch noch nicht mal so schlimm, vielleicht auch auf die
gezielt hinzuarbeiten.
Was aber ein Problem ist, weil wir sind ja hier unter der Religion der freien
Marktwirtschaft, Wenn du dann den Wettbewerb behinderst...
Und oder dadurch deine Leistungen für die Kunden schlechter werden.
Also wenn du eine marktbeherrschende Stellung ausnutzt, um Innovation zu bremsen,
damit du, damit die Kunden bei dir bleiben und das damit zum Nachteil der Kunden
ist oder du deine marktbeherrschende Stellung benutzt, um den Wettbewerb auszubremsen.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie hat Google denn seine marktbeherrschende
Stellung überhaupt erreicht?
Man sagt, die haben 90 Prozent Marktanteil bei generellen Suchmaschinen und
da wird jetzt schon direkt diskutiert. Da sagt Google natürlich so,
Leute, das ist doch keine marktbeherrschende Stellung.
Wir haben vielleicht 90 Prozent Marktanteil bei den Suchmaschinen im Web.
Aber die Leute, die was kaufen wollen, die suchen bei Amazon nach Produkten.
Da haben wir einen Marktanteil von null. Die suchen bei Spotify nach Musik,
die suchen bei TikTok, weiß nicht, ob man bei TikTok überhaupt suchen kann oder
ob das einfach in einem Fott auf einen einballert, die Leute suchen auf Facebook
X oder Mastodon nach Personen und so weiter.
Sie sagen, der Markt für Suche ist ja nicht nur der Markt für Websuche.
So, jetzt habe ich mir mal angeschaut, was Google so alles tut,
um die Suchmaschine Nummer 1 zu bleiben.
Sie sind in Browsern voreingestellt, das kennen wir,
das haben wir, also ist ja allen bekannt, dass ein Browser eine Searchbar hat
oder irgendwann war die Searchbar auch wieder weg, dann ist es die Addressbar,
wenn du da was eintippst, was keine URL ist, dann geht es zu Google.
Und dafür bezahlt Google gutes Geld, weil die Browserhersteller natürlich diese Funktionalität,
Oder den Defaultplatz verkaufen, den kann, da kann man auch DuckDuckGo einstellen,
da kann man auch, was gibt's noch für coole, startpage.com,
oder was auch immer einstellen oder wenn man so Internet zum Abgewöhnen,
kann man da auch Bing einstellen.
Alles möglich. Aber das lassen sie sich gut bezahlen.
Also es ging lange Zeit,
das Gerücht, dass irgendwie das so Apples größte Einnahme war,
irgendwie so als Einzelbetrag, was sie von Google dafür bezahlt bekommen,
dass bei ihrem Betriebssystem Google halt der Default ist.
Jetzt müssen, wenn du als Hersteller von Android-Geräten hingehst und sagst,
ich möchte gerne eine Google-App auf dem Gerät haben,
also zum Beispiel YouTube, ich möchte ein Android-Handy bauen,
da ist alles drauf, alles Google-frei, hier als Suchmaschine machen wir DuckDuckGo
und so weiter und dann möchte ich noch YouTube drauf haben.
Da musst du elf Google-Apps installieren, das ist quasi deren Bedingungen,
darunter die Google Search App, den Google Browser Chrome, wo dann wiederum
Google natürlich als Suchmaschine eingestellt ist und den App Store Google Play.
Das war glaube ich auch damals so ein größeres Thema oder so etwas ähnliches
war auch Thema bei der Frage nach
dem, nach dem, nach diesen Bluetooth Funktionalitäten der Corona Warn App.
Erinnerst du dich noch? Da musste man auch die Google Play Services,
wo dann auch einfach ein riesiger Rattenschwanz dranhing und die Leute gesagt
haben, ey, das ist irgendwie Mist.
Und dann haben Ende so freie Software-Coder die ganze Funktionalität nachprogrammiert,
damit die CyanogenMod und wie heißt das jetzt, Wie heißt der Nachfolger?
Das Google-freie Android, was man heute haben will.
Klingt nicht mehr so ein bekloppter Name wie Cyanogenmod, deswegen vergesse ich ihn auch.
Hab ich hier liegen, müsste ich jetzt... Aber die Google-freien Androids,
die konnten das da nicht nutzen. Ich schweife ab.
Und eine Suchmaske für Googles Suchmaschine muss prominent auf dem Homescreen
des Gerätes platziert sein, also so ein Widget für Google-Suche.
Das ist alles so Dinge, dass du eine Android-App haben kannst.
Und da kriegst du noch nicht mal Geld für. Das ist einfach die Bedingung von
Google, dass du jetzt beispielsweise YouTube auf ein Android-Gerät von vornherein
vorinstalliert haben darfst.
Wenn sich jetzt die Hersteller und Netzbetreiber dazu, also,
und das alles, da kriegst du kein Geld.
Und wenn sie sich jetzt aber verpflichten, parallel keine Apps anderer Suchmaschinen
zu installieren und auch nicht
auf die Existenz anderer Suchmaschinen hinzuweisen, dann bezahlt Google.
Und zwar eine Beteiligung am Werbeumsatz, der bei den Suchanfragen anfällt.
Also das ist schon, ne?
Also du kriegst alles, erst mal zwingen sie dich alles zu nehmen,
das kriegst du umsonst und wenn du dann noch alles andere da raushältst,
dann kriegst du Geld, aber wenn du nur eine App von denen haben willst,
dann kriegst du gar nichts.
Das ist schon, sag ich mal, ein Marktgebaren, was ein bisschen ellbögig ist, oder? Was meinst du?
Naja ich meine sie nutzen natürlich da einfach ihre Macht ist ja klar.
Sie wollen halt einfach präsent sein.
Diese ganze Google Play Store Geschichte und das Auslagern von Libraries war
ja schon so ein Move wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, das überhaupt erstmal aus
diesem Betriebssystem als solchen heraus zu halten.
Das ist ja an sich schon mal ganz sinnvoll erschienen, aber ist ja klar,
dass sie da mit den Muskeln spielen.
Ja genau und jetzt ist halt die Frage, das Verfahren wird jetzt lange dauern,
die Kläger müssen jetzt zeigen, dass es erstens dem Wettbewerb und auch den
Verbrauchern geschadet hat, denn nur Maßnahmen zum Nachteil des Wettbewerbs
oder der Konkurrenten wären noch kein Rechtsverstoß.
Also, es muss jetzt irgendwie einer kommen und sagen, Und weil das so war...
Ist meine Lebensqualität geringer, ja?
Und das wird natürlich vielleicht nicht ganz so einfach.
Aber was man bei der Gelegenheit noch mal kurz ansprechen kann,
Tim, du erinnerst dich doch bestimmt auch noch an die Verfahren hier beim mitgelieferten
Internet Explorer bei Windows XP oder was, das war doch die höchste Kartellstrafe,
die es je gab. Hast du das noch im Kopf?
Welchen Aspekt davon?
Überhaupt das Verfahren. Das ist ja jetzt auch schon älter als Google.
Im Kopf ist ein großes Wort. Ich hab das natürlich damals mitbekommen und ehrlich
gesagt, ich hab das auch ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig verstanden.
Also so sehr ich Microsoft damals nicht mochte.
Dieses Argument, dass der, dass ein Webbrowser nicht Teil des Betriebssystems
sein darf, das habe ich nie verstanden.
Ja das, also die Idee natürlich hier war, dass, also die Überlegung war natürlich hier,
oder die Argumentation von Mozilla war ja hier, ey wir machen aber auch einen
schönen Browser und Mozilla konnte natürlich schon relativ einfach belegen, dass der besser ist.
Es ist nicht so schwer gegen Internet Explorererweise nicht und haben halt gesagt,
naja dadurch, dass Microsoft hier den neuen Markt Internet und den Zugang dazu
fest in Windows einbaut, versauen sie uns überhaupt diesen Markt zu betreten.
Rückblickend betrachtet ein,
Also absurd, dass das die höchste Kartellstrafe ist, die es jemals gab, glaube ich.
Oder vielleicht gab es danach irgendwann nochmal höhere, aber es war auf jeden
Fall so die, eine absolute Irrsinn an Strafen, ne?
Auf jeden Fall hat es auch davon gezeugt, dass eigentlich zu dem Zeitpunkt noch
keiner so richtig gecheckt hat, was eigentlich Phase ist hier mit dem Internet und so.
Also ich persönlich konnte das nicht nachvollziehen, so sehr ich Microsoft jeden
Niedergang gegönnt habe in dem Moment, aber das war für mich kein nachvollziehbares Argument.
Wenn du so Dokus siehst über Bill Gates, ich glaube, der hat in dem Verfahren
irgendwie den Glauben an den Rechtsstaat verloren, weil er halt auch dieser
Argumentation nicht so folgen konnte.
Aber ich will das trotzdem referenzieren, weil es eben diese Voreinstellungsfrage,
was kriege ich mit dem Gerät geliefert, schon berührt.
Heutzutage, also bis jetzt ist noch keiner auf die Idee gekommen Apple irgendwie
Ärger zu machen oder so oder Microsoft liefert ja auch weiterhin einen Browser
mit ihren Geräten aus, ne?
Ja und ich meine das sind ja auch, also man erwartet das ja heutzutage geradezu,
das ist ja eine Kernfunktionalität.
Also ich finde das vollkommen richtig, dass das.
Computer ohne Browser?
Wie ein 5000 Euro Macbook ohne Simkartenslot, ohne Cellular Network. Oh wait.
Genau, aber da wird man jetzt drüber diskutieren und ich fand einige dieser
Praktiken, die ich da gelesen habe, wie also Google sich als Standard etabliert.
Die muss ich zugeben, die kannte ich so nicht.
Gut. Gibt's da noch was zu sagen?
Jetzt kommen wir zum nächsten Schritt, bei dem man Google ja unterstellt,
dass sie damit auch, oder wo man Google, wo man davor warnt.
Dass Google hier wieder eine marktbeherrschende Stellung ausnutzen möchte.
Jetzt kennen wir ja diese ganzen verhassten Cookies, allein schon deshalb verhasst,
weil wir ja immer noch diese sinnlose Situation haben, die mich echt mega nervt,
dass ich auf jeder scheiß Webseite mich erstmal wieder durch irgendeinen blöden Cookie banne.
Wer hat sich diesen Scheiß überhaupt einfallen lassen?
Aber der Hintergrund ist natürlich klar, man will irgendwie verhindern,
dass man irgendwie hintenrum ausspioniert wird auf irgendeine Art und Weise,
die man technisch aber sowieso nicht versteht.
Jetzt gibt's da natürlich auch viele Techniken, die da zum Einsatz kommen.
Vom ganz einfachen Third-Party-Cookie, ja,
die einfach, dass irgendjemand so mittrackt und auf anderen Webseiten dir dann
auslesen oder beschreiben kann oder halt einfach auch andere Methoden,
das sogenannte Fingerprinting, also dass man sozusagen User daran erkennt,
Nicht weil sie sich irgendwie einloggen sondern die surfen auf irgendwelchen
Webseiten rum aber man schaut dann halt so.
So okay, was hast du denn da für einen Browser? Du kommst mit dem Browser in
der und der Version auf dem und dem Betriebssystem.
Das steht ja dann alles drin in so einem User Agent drin.
Früher standen noch die Bildschirmauflösungen noch mit drin in diesem String und so weiter.
Also traditionell haben diese ganzen Webbrowser wirklich eine ganze Menge von
dir berichtet ohne jetzt deinen Namen zu nennen,
aber einfach so viel Metadaten in jeder einzelnen Anfrage, in jedem einzelnen
Klick mitgeliefert, dass wenn man halt das halbwegs klug zusammensortiert,
schon relativ gut jemanden wiedererkennen kann nach dem Motto ah hier kommt
genau diese Kombination.
Braucht man auch nicht mal vielleicht so ein Cookie. Naja das hat jetzt alles
ein bisschen Gegenbewegung erhalten,
diverse Browserhersteller haben jetzt angekündigt und teilweise auch schon umgesetzt,
dass sie diese ganzen Third Party Cookies nicht mehr machen und natürlich auch
zahlreiche andere Maßnahmen eingeleitet,
Um einfach unerwünschtes, unerlaubtes Tracking von irgendwelchen Webseiten im
Web, ich sag mal, zu reduzieren.
Und zwar in einem Maß zu reduzieren, dass halt die ganzen Werbeunternehmen schon nervös werden.
Weil die einfach nicht mehr auf diese ganzen Daten kommen, mit denen sie dann
an diesen Ausspielungssystemen teilnehmen können und mit Geld versorgt werden.
Das ist natürlich auch ein Problem für Google und deswegen hat Google jetzt
wohl auch eingesehen, so okay, alles klar, diese Türen werden sich weiterhin
schließen, wir müssen jetzt hier irgendwie was machen und ihr Vorschlag ist
halt diese Privacy-Sendbox.
Das ist sagen wir mal der Name unter dem das jetzt so läuft und man merkt schon
an dem Namen wie das so gespielt wird.
So nach dem Motto hier voll gut für dich sitze im Sandkasten geile Privatsphäre
total total sicher und schön für dich und jetzt vor einer Woche am siebten September
glaube ich war so das Rollout im Chrome von dieser Technologie und es kommt wohl auch für Android.
Wollen wir den Sandbox Begriff kurz einführen hier an der Stelle?
Gerne.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der allen so geläufig ist.
Ja, das stimmt.
Möchtest du? Also Sandboxing als technischer Begriff im Computing ist so die,
so ein Sicherheitskonzept, was quasi sagt, wenn irgendwo, also klassischerweise
bezog sich das erstmal so auf Programmcode.
Man will nicht, dass Software jetzt, nur weil ich jetzt irgendwie ein Programm
starte auf meinem Computer, dass diese Software dann gleich auf alles Zugriff
hat, auf meine Dateien, auf meine ganzen Daten und die sich dann irgendwie schnappt
und irgendwo in die Welt jagt. Das möchte man halt nicht.
Andererseits brauchen natürlich Programme aber auch Zugriff,
weil sonst funktionieren sie halt unter Umständen nicht, weil sie sollen ja
auch letzten Endes mit meinen Daten irgendwas tun. Also das ist so ein bisschen
so ein Dilemma an der Stelle.
Dieses Konzept von Sandboxing ist, dass man eben versucht diese Programme sozusagen
in so einen Sandkasten reinzusetzen,
so nach dem Motto du darfst jetzt hier erstmal nur mit den Förmchen spielen,
die ich dir hier reingelegt habe, aber wenn du jetzt in irgendeiner Form etwas
außerhalb dieses Sandkastens haben möchtest, dann musst du durch einen bestimmten
Prozess durchgehen, entweder schon von Anfang an, wenn.
Deine Software released wird, dass man dir von vornherein erlaubt auf irgendetwas
zuzugreifen, Netzwerk, Dateien oder so.
Solange es keine Schwachstellen gibt, davon ausgehen, dass wir relativ gefahrlos
auch nicht vertrauenswürdigen Code ausführen können und dass er die kritischen
Teile, die wir ihm nicht geben möchten,
Auch nicht bekommt, darf nicht an die Kamera, darf nicht an das Mikrofon,
darf nicht an meine Lokation und solche Dinge, gibt's ja erstmal alles so,
also diese funktioniert, das ist eine Sandbox.
Wobei Programme das natürlich auch immer versucht haben zu umgehen,
mit irgendwelchen Ausreden,
so nach dem Motto, oh ja ich muss hier immer total Bluetooth irgendwie,
weil kann ja sein, dass ich auf irgendwelche Geräte zugreifen muss und so,
schalt mal lieber ein und dann wurde das halt auch benutzt, um so ein Fingerprinting
zu machen, weil man dann wieder auf irgendwelche MAC Adressen zugreifen kann und so oder WLAN sieht.
Gibt aber auch den umgekehrten Fall, erinnert es dich noch, wenn man die Corona-Warn-App
auf Android installiert hat, da kam irgendwie so, ja hier, wir machen kein Tracking
und dann kam so die Warnmeldung, ey, der will auf deine Location zugreifen, ja.
Warum haben die davor gewarnt? Naja, weil die Corona-Warn-App auf Bluetooth
Low Energy Beacons zugreifen wollte und die grundsätzlich auch eine Positionierung erlauben.
Und deswegen auch irgendwie und deswegen musste man dem Ding dann doch quasi
Location Freigabe erteilen, was bei vielen Leuten für große Verwirrung gesorgt hat.
Ja, weil das Wording an der Stelle einfach nicht gepasst hat.
Ja, in irgendeinem Moment war dieses Wording halt ein bisschen älter als die
Corona Warn App, aber okay, ich glaube das Konzept haben wir jetzt erklärt.
Also du kannst als Code, du kannst alles machen als Code und solange die Sandbox
dicht ist, was sie nicht in der Regel nicht dauerhaft ist, aber solange sie
dicht ist, verbietet sie dir eine ganze Reihe an Dingen.
Und an dieser Stelle soll sie
erst mal verbieten, dass die Webseite so ein Third-Party-Cookie-Tracking
machen kann. Und das ist, glaube ich, ein sehr, äh, sehr heeres Ziel,
das wirklich komplett aus einem Browser auszubauen, oder?
Oder sagen wir mal so, diese Methode ist sowieso tot und muss durch irgendwas
anderes ersetzt werden.
Und unter diesem Namen Privacy Sandbox verbergt sich jetzt auch nicht nur eine einzige Technologie,
sondern es ist eigentlich so ein
Jutesack voll mit so ein raumbildendes Packmittel voll mit Technologien,
ich weiß nicht, es ist glaube ich so sechs, sieben, acht verschiedene Protokolle
und APIs, die hier vorgeschlagen werden, die für sich genommen auch alle erstmal
ganz, sinnvoll klingen.
Ja, also dass man irgendwie auch bestimmte Daten nicht mehr zum Fingerprinting benutzt werden kann.
Das ist einfach so bestimmte Zugriffe, die sich so etabliert haben im Web,
die man nicht haben will, dass die dann sozusagen da drin auch erstmal so nicht möglich sind.
Dass es stattdessen andere APIs gibt, die man dann benutzt, die eben dann,
die nicht so Privatsphäre-sensitiv sind. Das ist, sagen wir mal so der Sales-Pitch.
Dieser ganzen Geschichte.
Wir haben ein bisschen noch Schwierigkeiten glaube ich das technologisch komplett
zu beschreiben, weil es dann doch einige Verfahren sind, das muss man sich echt
nochmal genauer anschauen und das habe ich zumindest bisher mir im einzelnen
noch nicht alles angeschaut.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall eine ausführliche technische Beschreibung und wenn man
sich halt so die einzelnen Sachen anschaut, dann klingen die jetzt auch erstmal nicht so falsch.
Also gerade so diese passive Erkennung an diesem User-Agent,
also an der eigenen Sache und welche Sprachen ich ausgewählt habe und solche Sachen,
also es sind verschiedenste Verfahren und Vorschläge hier mit drin,
um sozusagen weniger Angriffsfläche für so ein ungewolltes Ausspionieren zu bieten.
Also sie benennen spezifisch drei Ziele.
Das eine ist, wir möchten, ich erzähle die mal in anderer Reihenfolge.
Als erstes möchten wir Third-Party-Cookies komplett eliminieren,
nicht mehr akzeptieren.
Die werden wir vollständig blockieren. Das ist einfach.
Das Zweite ist, die ganzen Workarounds,
die Tim gerade auch schon benannt hat, also eine Kombination aus Land,
User-Agent-String, den vorhandenen Devices,
den installierten Fonts und so weiter, daraus einen Fingerabdruck zu machen,
also alles, was ein JavaScript auslesen kann, was ihm etwas Individuelles über
dein Gerät sagt, muss auch alles wegmachen.
Ja, wir sagen, okay, also wir, Third-Party-Cookies weg,
Fingerprinting weg und dann,
naja, die Funktionalität, die man mit Cross-Site-Tracking macht,
die möchte, also das, was der Markt braucht, das bauen wir jetzt aber,
bauen wir anders neu,
damit wir gleichzeitig nix kaputt machen, denn wenn du Third-Party-Cookies deaktivierst
in deinem Browser, ja, wird halt nicht mehr so lange wird nicht mehr so weit kommen.
Ich glaube, dass in der Web-Erfahrung, die die jetzt hier fein sehen.
Da sagen sie, jetzt bauen wir für alles, was Cross-Site-Tracking an in Anführungszeichen
legitimen Anwendungsfällen hat,
da bauen wir jetzt andere APIs für in
unserem Browser ein, die dann auf unterschiedlichste Weisen funktionieren.
Und ich glaube, wenn wir uns die anschauen, was sie da bauen,
da wird's dann ein bisschen kompliziert.
Ich würde denen, ich würde das insgesamt sagen,
sie versuchen halt das, was normalerweise zentral irgendwo gesammelt wird,
eher lokal zu sammeln, damit dein Browser sich erst mal selber in ein Profil einordnet.
Beispielsweise in das Profil interessiert sich für Apple Produkte und dann sich die Werbung aussucht,
wenn er eine Seite besucht und da ist dann so, ja wir hätten hier Werbung für
Apple Produkte und dann sagt der Browser, ja das passt zu meinem Profil, gib das mal, ja.
Und dann hat er aber nur rausgegeben, ich interessiere mich für Apple-Produkte
und hat aber nicht rausgegeben, wofür du dich sonst noch alles interessierst.
Das scheint so der Gedanke zu sein,
dass sie sagen, wir holen, dass dein Profil kommt in Anführungszeichen in diese
Sandbox und dann werden dir Dinge angeboten und du machst den Abgleich lokal
und teilst nur deine Entscheidungen mit und dadurch verrätst du nicht so viel
über dein Profil in den darauf folgenden Requests, die du machst.
So würde ich sagen ist der ganz ganz ganz grobe Anspruch von diesem System zusammengefasst.
Genau das ist die sogenannte Topics API, also wir haben das übrigens auch schon
mal hier diskutiert, da war noch dieser erste Vorschlag unter dem Namen FLOC, was hieß das nochmal?
Federated. Federated creation of distributed cohorts. Also letztendlich, dass man keine zentral,
also dass man föderiert, also auf den Geräten Kohorten definiert,
denen die sich dann wiederum zuordnen, ohne dass es irgendwo eine zentrale Instanz
gibt, die weiß, wer in welcher Kohorte ist.
Das ist die wissenschaftliche Beschreibung von dem, was ich gerade versucht
habe einfacher zu erklären.
Auf jeden Fall, das fanden nicht so viele Freunde dieser Vorschlag und das ist
halt jetzt eben durch die von dir jetzt quasi beschriebene Topics API ersetzt worden.
Inwiefern das noch viel Ähnlichkeit hat mit dem alten Vorschlag kann ich jetzt
gerade nicht so richtig einschätzen.
Naja, also auf jeden Fall ist es ein Paket von Technologien, die.
Auf den ersten Blick erst mal ganz gut gemeint sind jetzt kann man natürlich
bei der Bewertung dessen und die geht dann natürlich auseinander ja kann natürlich jetzt sagen.
Okay also entweder man nimmt jetzt hier den maximalen Privacy Aspekt ein und
sagt so nichts darf auch nur im geringsten bei mir herausfinden was ich will
und ich will das nicht also Spoiler man kann das Feature auch abschalten.
Also im Chrome, ob das dann auch so ist, weiß ich nicht,
aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass man diese ganzen Technologien ablehnt,
ist die Frage, was ist jetzt die Alternative dazu, weil das ist ja jetzt erstmal ein Angebot.
So könnte man das irgendwie lösen und damit sind wir dann zumindest die alten
Methoden erstmal los, aber wir hätten sozusagen auch noch die Möglichkeit hier was zu machen.
Gibt's ja dann auch mal so diesen Aspekt, diese ganze Privatsphären Diskussion
im Netz, hat sich früher schon immer so ein bisschen in zwei Teile gespalten.
Da gab's so die einen Leute, die sagen, oh mein Gott,
das System will auf mich zugeschnittene Werbung senden,
Überwachung, dystopischer Staat, was geht so und dann gibt's so den anderen
Teil der Bevölkerung, der sagt, oh die Werbung ist auf mich zugeschnitten. Zugeschnitten, super.
Endlich ist der pinke Delfin, die Vibrator weg.
Ja genau, jetzt krieg ich immer Scheißsache, jetzt krieg ich endlich mal die
Sache, endlich das Helene Fischer Album, da hab ich schon lange gesucht.
Also die Bewertung, was gut und richtig ist, geht glaube ich bei vielen Leuten
auch wirklich auseinander und das ist offensichtlich auch hier, aber ich.
Aber Tim, da muss man schon fairnesshalber sagen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das Argument so plump war, dass ich kriege zielgerichtete Werbung,
sondern also es ist natürlich schon so, dass es einige,
sehr wenige Werbe-Netzwerke, Google davon das größte gibt,
oder ich weiß gar nicht, ob das noch das größte ist,
die letztendlich in jeder Webseite mit eingebunden werden und dass es tatsächlich so ist,
wenn du jetzt irgendwie mit so einem Standard-Browser dich einfach durch Standard-Seiten bewegst,
Sagen wir mal, du gehst auf Google,
gehst dann zu Spiegel Online, liest Nachrichten zu Süddeutschland, liest Nachrichten zu,
weiß ich,
zu wem noch, dass dann es Server gibt,
die unter Kontrolle von potenziell einem Unternehmen sind,
dass jeden einzelnen dieser Besuche mitbekommt,
inklusive wie lange du dich dort aufhältst und schon relativ viel mit erfassen
von deinem Webverhalten und wahrscheinlich auch sehr viel mehr mit erfassen als sie brauchen, ja.
Das ist jetzt erstmal so,
das ist auch der Grund, warum du vielleicht auf der nächsten Seite die gleiche Werbung wieder hast,
oder warum vielleicht so bestimmte Werbung, die du dir auf bestimmten Webseiten
geholt hast, dich dann noch weiter auf andere Webseiten mitverfolgt oder so,
das ist ja jetzt erstmal einfach so.
Und dass das potenziell sehr umfassende Profile sind, die da entstehen, ist auch ein Fakt.
Jetzt kann man sich natürlich überlegen, wie schlimm das ist.
Und ich würde auch sagen, dass manche dieses Risiko vielleicht ein bisschen überdramatisieren.
Gleichzeitig ist es, bin ich ja immer eher derjenige, der darauf eingeht,
dass das halt die Macht, die damit einhergeht, dass das Problem ist.
Aber das führt jetzt zu weit.
Es gibt noch einen Aspekt, den ich vielleicht noch mit einschieben will,
um das auch noch ein bisschen weiter zu relativieren.
Also das ist mittlerweile glaube ich, kannst du vielleicht,
noch mal mehr zu sagen, schon auch nicht mehr ganz,
so ein heißes Thema, aber wir hatten vor einigen Jahren ja.
Noch so diese Situation, haben. Wir erinnern uns hier an Cambridge Analytica,
Brexit, die ganze Beeinflussung der Wahl,
die letzten Endes zur Wahl von Donald Trump geführt hat,
wo eben ja auch über diese ganzen Profile,
die ja dann auch sehr viel über politische Gesinnungen und über Vorlieben und so weiter sagen,
Auch dann eben zielgerichtete, personalisierte Werbung,
Wahlwerbung eingespielt wurde, die dann eben genau versucht hat,
quasi die mentalen Schwachstellen dieser Leute auszunutzen, um ihnen dann sozusagen
irgendwas anzuzeigen, mit wovor sie jetzt am meisten Angst haben.
Also bist du ein Republikaner, dann wird dir einfach hier irgendwie,
ja und die Demokraten wollen irgendwie Abtreibung fördern und Act Now.
Oder wenn es halt Demokraten sind, wo das dann nicht so verfängt,
dann halt so, ja nee, hier so Hillary und Korruption und wähl mal lieber nicht.
Also das sind so Kollateralschäden, die eben auch alle was damit zu tun haben
und natürlich ist deshalb dieser ganze Privatsphäre-Aspekt nach wie vor super
super wichtig und mit diesem.
Vielleicht berechtigten, vielleicht auch nicht ganz so berechtigten Interesse
der Welt aber dann trotzdem doch irgendwie was mit Werbung machen zu können,
weil so viel Businessmodelle darauf basieren und weil ja auch nicht alles schlecht ist was Werbung ist,
Versucht man jetzt irgendwie eine Balance zu finden,
zu sagen, okay wir bauen jetzt hier mal so ein Set von Technologien,
die verhindern eine Menge von dem was früher möglich war und vielleicht auch alles,
aber wir bieten quasi hier so eine Tür an, wo man durchgehen kann,
wenn der User das erlaubt, wo dann die Webseiten einfach fragen können,
sag mal wie wärs denn mit Werbung über hmm, hmm, hmm,
würde dich das interessieren und der Browser kann das dann eben automatisch
beantworten und das tut er dann wiederum und da wird es halt creepy,
weil der Browser dann eben dir quasi ein bisschen dabei zuschaut,
was du eigentlich so machst und so liest und guckst und tust und so weiter,
weil um so ein Profil zu erstellen muss ja in irgendeiner Form eine Analyse stattfinden.
Und wenn die Analyse nicht mehr draußen stattfindet, dann muss sie ja quasi
in deinem eigenen Zimmer stattfinden.
So, da sind wir ja so ein bisschen wieder bei so einem, was darf auf meinem
Computer für Code laufen Diskussion.
Und ich glaube das ist auch so ein weiterer Aspekt, der hier als Schärfe mit
in die ganze Debatte mit reinkommt.
Genau und jetzt natürlich das große Thema und aus gutem Grund würde ich sagen
kann man auch echt sich dazu melden, jetzt sollte ausgerechnet die Idee von Google kommen.
Ja die jetzt diese Sache vorantreiben die einen Browser gekauft haben die Kartellverfahren
an den Backen haben die ohnehin die größten Bewegungen im Internet tracken und werbe finanziert sind.
Und ausgerichtet die kommen jetzt und sagen, wir haben eine Privacy-Sandbox
gebaut und wenn du dich darüber informieren willst, findest du echt keine.
Ey du findest keine coolen, keine verständlichen Beschreibungen davon,
so ein einfacher Callflow, wo einfach mal drinsteht, jo du besuchst ne Webseite
jetzt passiert folgendes,
das müssen ja die Leute die das programmieren, die müssen das ja alles wissen
und können und können es ja problemlos machen,
ja aber wenn du dir dann die, wenn du jetzt auf Privacy Dingens gehst,
Privacy Sandbox, Dann kommt da irgendwie ein anderthalb Minuten Video,
in dem eine Minute zehn lang erklärt wird,
was alles schlimm war am Third-Party-Cookie-Tracking und dann so,
oh, das ist alles weg, dank Google, danke schön, tschüss, nächstes Video,
ne, und das, also da könnten sie in der Kommunikation schon ein bisschen besser
sein, ja, wenn irgendwie ein Klick von dieser Privacy-Sandbox-Seite weg bist
du irgendwie auf irgendwelchen Dev-Dingern von Google Chromium.
Also da ist wirklich nicht vorgesehen, dass sich da jemand mehr mit auseinandersetzt,
um das wirklich zu verstehen.
Wie nicht überraschend, ne?
Naja, also, doesn't spark confidence,
muss ich mal so sagen, ne, also, zumal gerade,
wenn, also wenn Google sagt, wenn ausgerechnet Google sagt, hier pass mal auf,
wir bauen ein neues System in unserem Browser ein, der, Und dieses System dient
natürlich primär auch erstmal unseren finanziellen Interessen und macht unsere Konkurrenz kaputt.
Dann kann ich schon verstehen, dass sich ein paar melden.
Gleichzeitig diejenigen, viele von denen, die sich dann melden,
haben halt auch wirtschaftliche Interessen in der ganzen Suppe.
Nicht alle, ne, aber, oder die, vielleicht auch nicht die Mehrheit,
aber es gibt eine Reihe an Leuten, die jetzt auch nicht ohne wirtschaftliche
Interessen, nicht ohne wirtschaftliche Interessen sich da jetzt auf einmal gegenpositionieren.
Also es riecht schon so ein bisschen komisch. Wenn das jetzt irgendwie von der
IFF gekommen wäre, würde ich da mit weniger Argwohn drauf schauen,
als wenn es jetzt ausgerechnet von Google kommt.
Ja also ich meine bei Google, ich hab's jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht ausprobiert,
man kann wohl davon ausgehen, dass diese Privacy Sandbox so bei Default enabled ist.
Das ist ja sozusagen immer so die andere Frage, was ist der Default?
Ja weil würde jetzt sozusagen das Feature da drin sein und ja es wäre nicht aktiv.
Dann weiß ich nicht worüber ich mich groß aufregen sollte.
Ja aber da weißt du ja auch wie das läuft. Du installierst den Browser und dann
sagt der willst du mehr Privatsphäre dann drück hier den riesigen großen blauen Knopf.
Und da unten rechts diese ganz kleinen steht da so. Nee ich möchte ich möchte
ungeschützt ins Internet. Ja?
So, dann wirst du schon wissen, wie viel Prozent das benutzen.
Übrigens auf das Thema gebracht, könnte man den Kommentar auch noch kurz nennen,
von NTHD, denn ich sagte, ich würde auch die gerade gelaunchte Privacy Sandbox
und das katastrophale Web Environment Integrity Proposal nicht ganz relevant sehen.
Da kommen wir später zu dem Web Environment Integrity Proposal,
also in einer späteren Sendung.
Und er sagt natürlich ganz klar, oder sie, Google ist ein Werbeunternehmen,
dessen Vorstellung des Webs aus kostenfreien Inhalten und deren Werbefinanzierung besteht.
Dank der Dominanz von Chrome und Chromium, der Engine, das aktuell über 70%
der verwendeten Browser absteckt, können sie Standards eigenständig etablieren und sterben lassen.
Etwas mehr Aufmerksamkeit für diese gefährliche Monopolstellung,
fände ich auch jenseits der Privatsphäre-Bubble nicht verkehrt.
Okay, ich bin ja kein Chrome Nutzer, ich habe jetzt tatsächlich mal meinen Chrome,
der sich natürlich jetzt gerade letzte Woche auch automatisch aktualisiert hat,
gestartet und ich muss mich gleich korrigieren.
Tatsächlich ist es nicht automatisch aktiviert, aber es ist das erste,
was mir vor die Nase gelegt wird. Und es ist ganz interessant,
wie das Wording an dieser Stelle ist.
Also es kommt hoch mit eine Funktion zum Datenschutz bei Werbung aktivieren.
Das ist jetzt sozusagen hier so das Dialogfenster, was hier hochkommt.
Wir führen neue Datenschutzeinstellungen ein, mit denen du mehr Auswahlmöglichkeiten
in Bezug auf die angezeigte Werbung hast. Das ist natürlich schon mal schön,
ne? Mehr Auswahlmöglichkeiten. Super.
Werbethemen unterstützen Websites dabei, dir relevante Werbungen zu zeigen.
Deine Identität und dein Browserverlauf werden dabei geschützt.
Chrome kann aufgrund deines aktuellen Browserverlaufs auf Themen schließen,
die dich interessieren könnten.
Websites, die du besuchst, können dann relevante Themen von Chrome anfordern,
um die dir angezeigte Werbung zu personalisieren.
Du kannst dir die Werbethemen in deinen Einstellungen ansehen und diejenigen
blockieren, die nicht mit Websites geteilt werden sollen. Darüber hinaus werden
in Chrome Werbethemen automatisch gelöscht, die älter als vier Wochen sind.
Ja das finde ich schön, dass du das gerade noch vorgelesen hast,
das hatte ich nämlich auch so in Erinnerung, dass es da auch so eine Art Radiergummi
gibt, der so ein bisschen deine Interessen aktuell hält.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht unbedingt, ich kann mir auch vorstellen, also...
Die werden diese, die werden das Ding so gewählt haben, dass sie sagen so komm ey,
entweder wir haben es dem in vier Wochen verkauft, oder der hat sich das Sofa
halt einfach offline gekauft, aber wir brauchen dem jetzt keine Sofa Werbung
mehr zu zeigen, sicherlich auch damit schneiden die sich jetzt nicht in ihrem
Modell, in ihr Geschäftsmodell, ne.
Aber es gibt natürlich irgendwie alles, was irgendwie Sachen werden automatisch
gelöscht und so weiter, gibt den Nutzerinnen natürlich ein besseres Gefühl oder
ein gutes Gefühl, dass man da überhaupt eine Autonomie hat.
Oder eine Möglichkeit hat da reinzuschauen, Sachen zu löschen, wegzuklicken.
Und das ist ja, also, das haben wir auf jeden Fall jetzt nicht,
so viel kann man glaube ich sagen, oder?
Also jetzt kannst du alle deine Cookies löschen und dann wirst du halt über
Browser Fingerprinting und über deine Surfgewohnheiten sofort wiedererkannt.
Ja und diese ganzen Cookies, also ich meine das versteht doch echt keiner,
was das irgendwie ist. Das nervt auch einfach nur. Also wäre schön,
könnte man einfach mal wegschmeißen.
Ich hab das jetzt mal hier aktiviert, dann kommt der mir gleich hoch.
Du kannst es nie wieder deaktivieren, Tim. Den Knopf findest du nicht.
Da bin ich mir sicher. Ja, das ist eine andere Frage.
Ich guck mal hier im Chrome.
Oh, ich bin sogar eingeloggt.
Da kommt dann gleich weitere Funktionen zum Datenschutz bei Werbung. Jetzt verfügbar.
Also ich hab das jetzt aktiviert. Jetzt kommt sozusagen gleich weitere Funktionen, die verfügbar sind.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, was jetzt noch Neues kommt, aber ich glaube,
Erfolgsmessung von Anzeigen.
Ist die Funktion zur Erfolgsmessung von Anzeigen aktiviert, werden zwischen
Websites bestimmte Daten übertragen, um die Leistung der auf ihnen präsentierten Werbung zu messen.
Unter anderem wird erfasst zu welcher Uhrzeit welche Werbung eingeblendet worden.
Also das ist sozusagen diese Methode Werbe, wie nennt man das,
die Effektivität von Werbung sozusagen zu messen.
Von dir besuchte Websites können von Chrome Informationen abfragen,
um die Leistung ihrer Anzeigen messen zu können.
Du kannst Änderungen in den Einstellungen von Chrome vornehmen.
Jetzt kann ich aber hier nur OK klicken oder Einstellungen.
Naja mal gucken, irgendwelche Werbethemen schon gelistet. Momentan sind keine
Themen vorhanden. Okay gut, ist ja auch kein Wunder. Ich habe den gerade neu gestartet.
Ich kann dann Themen blockieren. Ja und,
ähm...
Dann von Websites vorgeschlagene Werbung, genau.
Ich kann auch einzelne Webseiten blockieren, das ist hier auch drin und dann
kommt noch die Erfolgsmessung von Anzeigen, die ist jetzt einfach eingeschaltet,
die habe ich nicht explizit eingeschaltet.
Genau das wollte ich nämlich auch, bei mir ist an, also bei mir ist sowieso
nur Ad Topics ist aus, Sites Suggested Ads ist an und Ad Measurement ist an.
Ja, also das müssen wir uns auch nochmal… Also das Problem ist,
ich muss echt sagen, dass das Frontend für die User ist hier glaube ich sehr
uninteressant, ist hier nicht der Teil wo man lernt was das für ein System ist,
ob es gut oder schlecht ist.
Natürlich nicht.
Na, das, also da, da, da, da, und das ist auch, ja, ich kann jetzt nochmal sagen,
das ist, es ist sehr geeignet, ähm, Argwohn zu erzeugen, was man da jetzt sieht,
ne, aber es klingt auf jeden Fall erstmal so.
Ja, meine, meine wilde These, angenommen alle Browser der Welt,
alle, werden jetzt mit diesem Feature ausgestattet. Mh.
Würde die Welt untergehen?
Tim ist, also nur weil jetzt die letzte Generation sich um den Weltuntergang
Gedanken macht, müssen die ja nicht jedes Thema mit dem Weltuntergang direkt aufwiegen, ja?
Also, weißt du, das ist auch nicht fair.
Ja, Entschuldigung, so eine andere Formulierung.
Du kannst jetzt sagen, wäre das Internet eine bessere Welt?
Würde das Internet dann für uns alle besser funktionieren? Wären die Werbepartner
glücklich und werden die Kunden glücklich? Ich kann es ja ausschalten,
so und dann ist ja auch irgendwie Ruhe im Karton, das ist so ein bisschen das
Versprechen, das wäre ja eigentlich ganz schön.
So kann ich jetzt das einschalten und trotzdem so das Gefühl haben ich sitze
immer noch im Sandkasten und da kommt jetzt keiner rein oder da kommt jetzt
nichts raus was ich nicht möchte dass es rauskommt vielleicht keine Ahnung muss man mal gucken.
Man kann nur mit der kleinen Schippe Sand rausheben.
Ja genau, also mit Sicherheit wird es auch erstmal Fehler geben,
vielleicht konzeptionelle Fehler, vielleicht einfach technische Umsetzungsfehler,
die in irgendeiner Form ausgenutzt werden können, aber mal salopp formuliert,
könnte ja auch sein, dass dadurch alles besser wird.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, haben wir noch irgendwelche Risiken übersehen mit Sicherheit?
Aber ich würde das auch mal jetzt ein bisschen ergebnisoffener diskutieren wollen.
Warum regen sich alle über dieses Web Integrity so auf? Das habe ich noch nicht so ganz verstanden.
Das im Prinzip DRM für Webseiten ist, wo du,
die dir eine Reihe an Features im Web ermöglichen sollen,
die du sonst potenziell nur, ja vielleicht mit obfuscated Code hinkriegst.
Also kannst du mal ein Beispiel nennen?
Ja ich glaube das einfachste Beispiel ist Videostreaming. Wenn du Video über
den Browser streamst, am Ende gibt es da nur Kontexte, die passieren bis du das Video siehst.
Am Ende gibt es einen MP4 Renderer und der spielt dir das Video.
Ja und alles was auf dem Weg dazwischen gemacht wird, ist irgendeine Zauberei
um dich daran zu hindern auf einfachem Weg einfach das Video herunter zu laden.
Und das gibt's ja jetzt schon lange, diese Funktion. Das ganze Netflix Streaming
im Web und so weiter, das hatten wir ja schon vor ein paar Jahren, diese DHM.
Ja und wie gesagt, das macht's ja aber nur schwerer und nach meinem Verständnis
ist es sicherlich nicht unmöglich so ein Netflix Video runterzuladen.
Es ist aber natürlich erschwert. Mit dem Web Integrity soll es im Prinzip so
sein, dass du, dass es letztendlich Code gibt, den du nicht mehr vollständig
nachvollziehen und überwachen kannst.
Oder und vor allem nicht mehr verändern kannst in seiner Integrität.
Und das verkaufen sie dir als hey, jetzt kriegst du ein sichereres Web.
Aber dass die Webseiten, die uns ausgeliefert werden, nicht integer sind,
ist ja nun wirklich nicht unbedingt unser Problem. Das ist also,
eher eine Lösung für DRM als Web. Und ich meine, die müssen sich ja eh sehr
bemühen, das Web zu retten, ne?
Und das machen sie halt, dass sie sagen, die Echtheit der Webseite und der Kontexte wird bestätigt.
Schauen wir uns nochmal genauer an, aber theoretisch kannst du damit Leute aussperren,
wenn sie einen nicht genehmigten Browser haben. Oder ein nicht genehmigtes Betriebssystem
oder vielleicht auch ein Plugin, was du nicht möchtest.
Im Prinzip sowas wie, dein Browser macht eine Remote Attestation zu der Webseite und sagt hier.
Ich bin so, wie du dir das vorgestellt hast.
Also wenn ich das richtig verstehe, Environment Integrity ist eher ein Schutz
von Webseiten vor den Clients,
um sicherstellen zu können, dass die Clients richtige Menschen sind,
also sozusagen so Bild in Capture, dass man in irgendeiner Form das sicherstellt
und damit quasi den Browsern etwas auferlegt,
was sie nachweisen müssen, was dann wiederum die Auswahl der Clients gegebenenfalls
einschränkt in dem Moment, wo die Webseiten einfach sagen, wenn du das nicht hast, dann liefere ich.
Ich dir auch sozusagen nichts.
Auch hier steckt natürlich ein Problem dahinter. Ich würde das jetzt erstmal
mit diesem DRM Beispiel nicht so nennen, sondern hier geht es ja eher darum,
und auch das ist ja ein nachvollziehbares Problem.
So DDoS Attacken irgendwie, also und generell Zugriffe auf Webseiten,
die eben verhindern sollen, dass.
DDoS ausgerechnet mit einer kryptographischen Operation verhindern zu wollen.
DDoS attacken, entschuldige ich hatte nicht DDoS also denial of service also
sozusagen in irgendeiner Form Zugriffe zu machen die dazu gedacht sind entweder
den Dienst als solchen unter Stress und damit außer Dienst zu stellen oder die
in irgendeiner Form Crawler darstellen zum Auslesen von Daten und so weiter.
Es gibt ja genug Ärger, die man haben kann als Webseitenbetreiber,
der real ist, der von Clients kommt.
Und hier drückt sich, glaube ich, so ein bisschen dieser Wunsch aus,
da wäre aber schön, wenn wir mal wüssten, dass da auf der Gegenseite auch ein
interessierter Mensch sitzt.
Aber naja, gut.
Okay, aber das Thema, wir wollten uns glaube ich primär der Privacy Sandbox widmen.
Ja, ich würde als vorsichtiges Fazit, okay Weltuntergang wird das jetzt nicht,
da bin ich bei dir, also sagen wir mal so, wenn das zum Weltuntergang führt,
bin ich zumindest überrascht.
Meine Wetten gehen gerade eher auf Klimawandel oder halt Donald Trump oder so,
da bin ich jetzt noch nicht bei. Ahaha, ähm...
Wird es zu einer guten Welt führen? Auch nicht. Wird es potenziell zu einer
besseren Situation führen?
Werden wir sehen. Auf jeden Fall sag ich mal, das ist aber auch nicht schwer,
weil die jetzige Situation wirklich nicht besonders geil ist. Oder?
Aber es wird auf jeden Fall dazu führen, dass wir eine Menge Kommentare dazu bekommen.
Dafür haben wir dann die Webintegrity Potential.
Kommentare jetzt, nur noch wenn ihr vorher auch digital nachweisen könnt, dass ihr Integra seid.
Nur noch von neuen iPhones.
Kommen wir zum nächsten Thema oder?
So, Chatkontrolle.
Letzte Woche haben wir noch darüber gesprochen und da hatte ich eine Zeitleiste
geschildert, wann das da in die heiße Phase geht. Die hat sich jetzt relativ stark verändert.
Die ist sehr viel dichter geworden, denn schon in zwei Wochen wollen die EU-Staaten
die Chatkontrolle beschließen.
Andrej hat da wieder ein schönes Protokoll veröffentlicht. Die sind aber trotzdem
noch im Clinch. Es ist unklar, wie sie sich einigen.
Und zwar ist das die Arbeitsgruppe der Justiz und Innenminister. Und die möchten...
Ja, am 28.
September ihren Beschluss fassen.
Jetzt stellt sich die Frage, wie wollte er das machen? Einig sind sie sich noch nicht.
Die spanische Ratspräsidentschaft will das ja durchdrücken und beschließen,
haben wir auch darüber gesprochen, dass sie sehr ambitioniert ist,
direkt noch Kryptographie mit verbieten will und damit mehr oder weniger überrascht
ist, überhaupt so viele Abstriche machen zu müssen.
Und wir erinnern uns auch, was ich in der letzten Woche, in der letzten Sendung
zitiert habe, vier Staaten mit mindestens 35 Prozent der Bevölkerung können
eine Sperrminorität bilden.
Das wäre realistisch.
Polen, Niederlande, Schweden, Österreich und vielleicht noch Deutschland.
Und da ist jetzt natürlich eine
ganz andere Situation, oder ist jetzt hier eine ganz andere Situation.
Deutschland ist im Moment noch in diesen Arbeitsgruppen dagegen,
sagt wesentliche Änderungen sind erforderlich, dass wir hier überhaupt mitmachen können.
Und jetzt müssen, sagen wir mal, die haben nicht mehr so viel Zeit zum umkippen.
Das ist, glaube ich, das Fazit. Währenddessen ist noch eine,
also das ist jetzt heiße Phase, aber 28.
September, wichtig. Und währenddessen ist noch eher so ein Randnotiz,
aber wir haben das ja hier auch nicht so behandelt oder nur am Rande behandelt,
dass diese ganze Chat-Kontrollenummer, ja, ohne Ende irgendwie von Ashton Kutcher vorangebracht wird.
Den ein mir nicht bekannter mensch aber der ich weiß dass der in hollywood star ist der.
Ja hier mit ey passt auf mit AI tun wir jetzt endlich was gegen den dokumentierten
Kindesmissbrauch im Internet,
da bei der EU irgendwie offene Türen
eingerannt ist und dann tanzen die alle um
den rum und meinten ja großartig der Kutscher
ja und jetzt ist
rausgekommen dass der in einem Strafverfahren
wegen in diesem Fall zweifacher Vergewaltigung sich in einem Brief für den angeklagten
und eben nachher auch verurteilten Schauspieler Danny Masterson eingesetzt hat.
Also der war wegen zweifacher Vergewaltigung vor Gericht.
Laut Anklage hatte er die Person, seine Opfer vorher unter Drogen gesetzt.
Und er wurde auch verurteilt, aber Ashton Kutcher hat sich dann noch für den eingesetzt.
Sagt er, dass er hätte ihn nie angelogen, hat sich für ein geringeres Strafmaß
eingesetzt, sei keine Bedrohung für die Gesellschaft, einer der wenigen Menschen,
die er alleine mit seinen Kindern lassen würde.
Das sieht jetzt nicht so gut aus, wenn du auf der einen Seite rumrennst mit
deinen KI-Startups und das Internet überwachen willst und auf der anderen Seite
dich noch für Leute einsetzt,
die nicht nur einmal schwere Verbrechen begangen haben.
Hat aber wahrscheinlich nicht so sehr geholfen, aber sieht nicht so gut aus.
Aber ja, man ist ja manchmal verwundert, welche Wendungen solche Dinge noch nehmen.
Ja und dann gibt es eigentlich noch, da bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher,
ob man das besprechen will, vielleicht kurz als Meldung, es wurde eine russische
Exil-Journalistin mit Pegasus gehackt.
Zum Zeitpunkt der Infektion hat sie sich in, glaube ich, sogar in Deutschland
befunden, das bedeutet nicht, dass der Angriff aus Deutschland kam.
Bei einer russischen Exil-Journalistin würde man natürlich vermuten,
war wahrscheinlich Russland, das die gehackt hat.
Allerdings geht eigentlich keiner davon aus, dass Russland Pegasus hat.
Überlegen, ob es vielleicht Aserbaidschan, Kasachstan oder Äzbekistan waren,
die das für Russland getan haben.
Aber auch bei denen gibt es keine Beweise, dass sie den Staatstrojaner von NSO gekauft hätten.
Also unabhängig davon, wer jetzt diese Infektion vorgenommen hat,
ist glaube ich relativ klar, dass sie wahrscheinlich im Interesse Russlands
stattgefunden hat und ja,
das sollte einen dann nochmal mit nochmal anderen Augen auf Pegasus und NSO blicken lassen,
wenn man nicht vorher schon sich relativ darüber im klaren war,
dass das halt ein sehr übles Unternehmen ist, mit dem man eigentlich nicht zusammenarbeiten
möchte, dass man auch nicht fördern möchte.
Tja, das war's eigentlich, so wäre meine Einschätzung dazu.
Ich versuche in der Zwischenzeit hier Chrome irgendwie meine Vorlieben durchsurfen.
Willst du mir deine Surfvorlieben anzeigen lassen?
Dritter Anbieter Cookies blockieren musste ich aber jetzt auch erstmal ausschalten,
also nur weil ich das neue Feature eingeschaltet habe heißt noch lange nicht,
dass die dann auch gleich blockiert wurden, aber zumindest gibt es diese Funktion.
Do not track muss ich auch erstmal wieder einschalten.
Ja gut das kannst du, ist ja egal das ignorieren ja eigentlich alle oder?
Ich werde auf jeden Fall gleich gewarnt wenn ich das einschalten will.
Oh wenn du das einschaltest wird eine Anfrage in deinem Browser aufgenommen.
Welche Auswirkungen die es hat hängt davon ab ob eine Website auf die Anfrage
reagiert und wie diese interpretiert wird. Angst Angst Angst.
Ja bestätigen ich will das haben ich versuche jetzt nur gerade die stelle zu
finden wo meine ganzen neuen tollen daten also ich will jetzt wissen welche themen mich hier.
Internet surfen du hast ja gerade erst angemacht.
Ich habe ja schon ein bisschen ja das werbethema hier ist gefunden immer noch
keine themen. Krass. Da habe ich jetzt hier irgendwie Netzpolitik Org.
Ja der hat natürlich eine Lernphase, soweit ich das verstehe.
Ja ja das ist nicht, dass er beim ersten Mal sofort dann.
Gleich loslegt, ja.
Mal gucken, ich kann ja immer so ein bisschen bewusst rumsurfen und ich mach
nur, aber nicht mehr in dieser Sendung oder du kannst ja dann,
du kannst jetzt mal eine Woche surfen und dann gucken wir mal morgen,
dann gucken wir in der nächsten Sendung mal deine Interessen.
Genau.
Bin ich ja mal gespannt. Du kannst ja ein paar rausnehmen, kannst ja sagen welche
du rausgenommen hast dann.
Ich bin ein offenes buch was ich habe nichts zu verbergen im internet nix zu verbergen.
Langweilig.
Internet vielleicht schon aber lokal auf meinem browser.
Ja vor meinem browser vertraue ich der ist ja von google ganz innovativer browser ist das.
So Leute, das war es dann auch schon von uns diese Woche. Und dann hören wir
uns nächste Woche irgendwie wieder.
Das versuchen wir ja.
So machen wir das. Alles klar. Das war es. Bis später. Tschüss. Tschüß!
Bis dann.